[Music]
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
hey Bruce I could fix things
um
dear parents
you changed the past and you're changed
the future
who the hell are you
[Music]
yeah I'm Batman
[Applause]
hero
Noah
hi I love you thank you you seem very
nice
so we're like in the future no wait
we're not in the future I was supposed
to be back in the present but I'm still
in the past and there's not supposed to
be two of me hey do the thing again fine
I went back in time to save my mom
but I completely destroyed history
changed the future
I created a world with no metahumans
want some help
I'm Batman
this world must die what's the way
Batman what do we do we try not to die
what did you do
no nobody dies
[Music]
El